this is John Delaney with Ramsey Network
it's good to see you today I hope you do
well today we are talking about what to
do
when your loved ones when your wife your
partner your mom your dad spins out with
anxiety and I got an incredible email
from a dude named Chris and we're gonna
spend the next couple of episodes
working through it this guy's awesome
everybody needs to be a husband like
this dude a partner like this dude check
it out here's the email dr. John my wife
struggles with anxiety and has bouts
with binge eating she's been talking
with a professional there's been
improvement but I feel the focus is on
the result binge eating so if I
understand your videos correctly and to
use your analogy her treatment isn't
even focused on turning the fire alarm
off its focused on not lighting another
match after the alarm has sound yes dude
you are on it's perfect if you don't
know what Chris is talking about with
the fire alarm analogy check the link
below go watch the video everything you
know about anxiety is wrong part 1 2 & 3
you can buzz right through them but it
just talks about anxiety is a fire alarm
it's just an alarm in a kitchen that's
on fire that we've created or that we've
been dropped into nothing more nothing
less and he is right on okay so stop
here go watch that video if you don't
know buddy's talk him out and then come
back and join us so Chris goes on to say
I want to help her put out fires and
save the kitchen my wife is amazing
she's a career successful a fantastic
mother and wonderful spouse the problem
is from an ignorant spouses perspective
11 humility
she places impossible measures on
herself she has to have a perfectly
clean house a constantly engaged 1 year
old a full meal on the table be the
perfect spouse and be a perfect employee
she's a caretaker at heart and relaxing
makes her feel guilty especially when
there is something to be done which
there always is welcome to being a woman
in the 21st century awesome that you're
seeing this Chris I've tried taking
things off her plate but she adds
something else to it in my eyes she
already is what she almost kills herself
trying to be how do I help shoulder her
burden and be in
more supportive spouse and get this
everybody I want to be a fire
extinguisher not fuel dude like I said
earlier Chris I'm nominating you for
husband of the year for seeing and
experiencing things in your wife for
wanting to honor her and love her and be
supportive but being humble enough to
say I don't know what to do man I'm
watching the person I love burn a hole
through their own soul which then burns
a hole through our home burns a hole
through everybody around us dude your
wife is experiencing what I call the
curse of the 21st century woman they
have been told since they were born you
can be anything you can do everything
and you can have everything all at the
same time they've been told you don't
need other people because you can do
everything the people around you will
probably fail you and there's been
experiences over their life where they
are judged on achievement on what you
can accomplish what everything looks
like oh and by the way here's a trillion
Pinterest posts and Instagram stories to
show you give you pictures of what life
is supposed to be how perfect it's
supposed to be and over the arc of that
story people are rewarded for
achievement for doing for serving to
making sure everyone else's needs are
taken care of and that wires itself into
a young woman's DNA and of course I'm
not a woman myself so I haven't
experienced this but this is just from
countless conversations and coaching
sessions with women over the years so
here's a couple of things I want us all
to wrap our head around but you
specifically Chris number one I didn't
get a hint of this here but I feel like
I need to say it we've got to stop
treating our partners like machines
people aren't broken number two people
aren't puzzles to solve so people aren't
machines that are broken and people are
not puzzles to solve they are humans to
be with and so if we approach someone
that we love who we see spinning we see
out of control we see struggling our
first impulse is to especially as dude
is to how do I fix this
how do I help how do I
Cert myself and become a solution to a
series of problems and I want to
challenge that approach and say how can
I just be with because what people are
struggling with in this situation so
often is a lack of connection a lack of
true value right so Chris I'm just gonna
make some assumptions fair or not fair I
would almost guarantee that your wife
has experienced some lack of control in
her childhood home or in her high school
college experience I don't know how long
you all have been married but my guess
is she has experienced some lack of
control in her life I would almost guess
that she's experienced some sort of
trauma to whether that is acute
something happens and she had some
negative experiences or there's some
brother in the house that got more
attention there was somebody else that
got the attention there was a mom who
was struggling there was a dad who had
issues we all have issues right but
there was a dad who had some challenges
and she had some sort of neglect so it's
either acute trauma or neglect and
somewhere along the way she achieved
homeostasis she achieved value by making
sure everyone around her was taken care
of by achieving by scoring points in
some game that none of us can win right
there is no win to this and when you
throw a kid in the mix and a husband in
the mix and a mortgage in the mix and in
business accomplishment into the mix all
of that just gets spun up and spun out
so you're watching the woman you love
grind herself to the floor so here are
three or four things Chris you can do
right now okay number one I want you to
practice SOS skin-on-skin contact three
or four times every day with your wife
so start the day right when you get up
when you both get up either right when
you're about to leave for work or when
you get home from work and then right
before bedtime and it doesn't have to be
intimate sexual contact it can just be
touching feet
the most effective way I've heard and
seen is holding hands and looking her in
the eye and just tell her dude some
quack on the youtubes told us that we
should do this for 30 days okay but I
want you to hold her hands look her in
the eye and say tell me about your day
tell me how you're doing and when she
responds to you say thank
or say that sucks or say that's awesome
I'm proud of you what a gift
thank you for sharing that and that's it
no advice no well you know you should be
doing in I'll call that dude none of
that just connect the second thing I
want you to do is ask her if you can
join her in a counseling session ask her
if you can start going together you can
either join her in her current sessions
with her current therapist or y'all can
go see somebody together and the
importance of that is you looking at her
saying I want to learn the skills honey
to be a better support to you in our
home I want to love you better I want to
learn tools that I can support you
better and just that sentence alone it's
gonna let her know I've got support and
care the third thing I want you to do
comes from Emily and agofsky's work and
she's talking more about sex but it
applies all over a partnership in a home
I want you to look for a ways to turn on
the ons and turn off the offs it says
some of these things that she feels
compelled to do all the time perfect
house make dinner take care of the kids
I want you to start finding ways that
you can gently quietly and without
fanfare take these things from her and
you're right right away she's gonna
refill that it's gonna be like sticking
your hand in a bucket of water pulling
it out she's gonna fill itself right
back up with more time more things but
as you start to pull these things off
and here's the magic secret sauce and
this is number four every week sit down
with her and say hey what does this week
look like for us what does the week look
like moving forward what's your picture
this week can it look like you paint a
picture you craft a vision of what this
week is going to look like in this week
only and over two weeks four weeks six
weeks she will begin to feel a peace
because all anxiety is is fear of the
future fear of things I can't control
it's an alarm and planning controlling
the controllables
being in connection with somebody over
time and silences those alarms and she's
gonna have to do the hard work probably
with a professional to shift her
identity into being okay with the
wonderful extraordinary woman that you
write about here knowing that when she
looks in the mirror
she's a person of value not because of
what she can achieve not because how
much peace she's keeping in the house
just because she's hurt that's enough so
if you're watching this you know why did
you just say to hold hands and look her
in the eyes you weirdo why don't you
tell her to go to the therapist or we're
gonna make a plea and that's gonna make
it better listen watch the next two
videos and I'm gonna unpack why in the
short-term
this helps folks that you love who are
struggling from anxiety and after that
we're going to talk about how to
co-create an ecosystem did it's
fireproof that doesn't catch on fire all
the time the alarms aren't always going
off but y'all can do that together so
dr. John Delaney with Ramsey Network
subscribe send these to your friends who
are strung with anxiety I'm getting your
emails that ask John at Ramsey solutions
calm I'm getting them from all over the
country my emails just blowing up it's
so dope I'm gonna keep responding to
them thank you so much follow me at John
to learn all this stuff whatever hey
have a good week